hemos visto las diferentes técnicas para
encontrar límites en varios vídeos y
ejercicios pero a veces es útil pensar
en estrategias que nos ayuden a elegir
qué técnica usar esto es lo que vamos a
hacer en este vídeo
este es un diagrama de flujo
desarrollado por el equipo de khan
academy y aquí vamos a ver cómo funciona
este diagrama quizá les parezca
complicado al principio pero ya verán
que lo comprenderán mejor una vez que lo
analicemos el objetivo es encontrar el
límite de fx cuando x tiende a a lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es
sustituir x con a para ver qué sucede
hay que evaluar efe y de acuerdo a este
diagrama de flujo si f vea es igual a un
número real entonces terminamos aunque
hay una nota aquí que dice probablemente
y la razón de esto es que el límite
puede ser algo distinto al valor de la
función evaluada en a a veces coincide
que son iguales de hecho esta es la
definición de una función continua que
ya vimos en vídeos anteriores pero a
veces no son lo mismo esto no se cumple
necesariamente si tenemos una función
que tenga un punto de discontinuidad
como el que estoy dibujando o tenga un
salto discontinuo como
con una función que se vea así en estos
casos no se cumple que sean iguales pero
si en el punto en donde queremos
calcular el límite al aproximarnos a
este punto la función es continua y se
comporta digamos que normal entonces
esto es algo que debemos tener en mente
primero tratar de evaluar la función en
ese valor en general si tratamos con
funciones comunes y corrientes como x
cuadrada o expresiones racionales o
trigonométricas como éstas y al
evaluarlas nos da como resultado un
número real probablemente hayamos
encontrado lo que buscamos si tratamos
con una función que tiene muchos casos
especiales y está definida por partes
como hemos visto en vídeos anteriores
entonces es posible que no encontremos
el límite que buscamos y también debemos
ser cuidadosos si al ver la gráfica de
la función en el punto am la función no
es continua o da un salto pero en
general esta es una buena regla si
tratamos con funciones comunes y
corrientes o que son continuas al
evaluarse en el punto x igual a am
entonces es probable que encontremos un
límite de esta manera ahora veamos los
otros escenarios
qué pasa si al evaluar la función el
resultado es un número que divide a 0 en
este caso es probable que se trate de
una a sin tota vertical qué significa
esto veamos el ejemplo de acá el límite
cuando x tiende a 1 de 1 / x 1 si
tratamos de evaluar esta expresión
sustituyendo uno en lugar de x entonces
tenemos uno entre uno menos uno que es 1
entre 0 por lo que caemos en el caso de
la 5ta vertical y si queremos comprender
lo que sucede en este caso o verificar
que en efecto se trata de una cinta
vertical podemos evaluar la función con
algunos números y tratar de graficar la
por ejemplo digamos que hay una a sin
total vertical en x igual a 1
esta es la asiento está vertical y ahora
vamos a usar algunos valores para
evaluar la función por ejemplo valores
de x mayores a 1 en estos casos el
denominador va a ser positivo y si
usamos varios valores podemos tener una
gráfica como esta y si después usamos
valores menores a 1 los resultados serán
negativos y podemos tener una gráfica
así de ésta
podemos verificar que hay una asín total
vertical habrá casos muy especiales en
los que no necesariamente tenemos una
asín total vertical un ejemplo es 1 / x
- x esta función es indefinida para
cualquier valor de x por lo que es
seguro que no tenemos una cinta está
vertical aquí pero como mencioné antes
estos son casos muy especiales la
mayoría de las veces encontramos así
notas verticales aquí digamos que
nuestro límite no cae en alguno de estos
casos
qué pasa si al evaluar la función
tenemos un cero sobre cero aquí tenemos
un ejemplo de esto el límite cuando x
tiende a menos 1 de esta expresión
nacional vamos a evaluar la menos 1 al
cuadrado es 1 menos uno negativo es más
uno menos dos por lo que tenemos cero en
el numerador en el denominador tenemos
menos 1 al cuadrado es uno menos 2 x
menos 1 es más 2 menos 3 nos da igual a
a esto se le conoce como forma
indeterminada si seguimos el diagrama de
flujo pasamos al lado derecho de esta en
donde hay varias técnicas para tratar de
encontrar el límite
algo que está en forma indeterminada y
en futuros vídeos es probable que
aprendan otra técnica que usa un poco
más de cálculo que se llama la regla del
hopital que no veremos aquí justamente
porque involucra cálculo mientras que
las técnicas que tenemos acá pueden
aplicarse sin tener que usar cálculo
algunas son técnicas algebraicas y
algunas son técnicas trigonométricas lo
primero que nos recomiendan hacer
especialmente si tenemos una expresión
racional como ésta cuyo resultado está
en forma indeterminada es tratar de
factorizar la es decir tratar de
simplificar esta expresión esta
expresión del ejemplo se puede
simplificar esto es igual a x menos 2
por x 1 entre veamos x menos 3 por x + 1
si no comprenden nada de lo que acabo de
hacer les recomiendo que vean los vídeos
que tenemos sobre factorización de
polinomios o factorización de
cuadráticas con esta factorización
podemos ver que la expresión se puede
simplificar siempre que x no sea igual a
menos 1 estas dos cosas se pueden
cancelar podemos decir que esto es igual
a x2 entre x menos 3 para
diferente a -1 a veces a las personas se
les olvida agregar esta parte pero es
importante hacerlo si queremos ser
rigurosos matemáticamente esta expresión
es idéntica a esta porque esta expresión
no está definida para x igual a menos 1
aunque podríamos sustituir x igual a
menos 1 aquí y ahora así obtener un
valor
así que si sustituimos x x menos 1
aunque aquí diga que no se puede hacer
para que sea matemáticamente equivalente
esto sería menos uno menos dos que es
menos tres entre menos uno menos tres
que es menos cuatro así que el resultado
de esto es tres cuartos si esta
condición no estuviera aquí podríamos
evaluar esta expresión directamente
porque ahora quedó como una función
común y corriente y si pudiéramos
evaluarla en menos uno entonces
probablemente encontraríamos su límite
vamos a repasar lo que hicimos factor
izamos y simplificamos la expresión
después evaluamos la expresión
simplificada y ahora sí podemos
encontrar el valor que estamos buscando
en este ejemplo el límite
es tres cuartos lo que acabamos de
revisar hasta el momento se puede
categorizar como la mayoría de los
ejercicios de límites que nos vamos a
encontrar las siguientes técnicas son un
poquito más sofisticadas si tenemos una
forma indeterminada en especial si tiene
radicales o es racional con radicales
podemos intentar multiplicarla por su
conjugado en este ejemplo de aquí si
queremos evaluar la función en x igual a
tenemos la raíz cuadrada de 4 menos 2
entre 4 4 que es igual a 0 entre 0 esta
es una forma indeterminada para aplicar
esta técnica sobre todo cuando tenemos
expresiones radicales vamos a tratar de
deshacernos de estos radicales y
simplificar la expresión vamos a
reescribir el ejemplo raíz de x menos 2
/ x menos 4 vamos a conjugar la
multiplicando por raíz de x + 2 / raíz
de x + 2 es esta expresión entre la
misma expresión por lo que no estamos
cambiando para nada el valor de la
expresión original
esto va a ser igual a si tuviéramos a b
x + b tendría la diferencia al cuadrado
es el cuadrado de la raíz de x menos 4
aunque el cuadrado de la raíz de x va a
ser igual a x solità lo reescribimos y
nos queda x menos 4 entre x menos cuatro
raíz de x más 2 esto nos sirve porque
ahora podemos cancelar estos x menos
cuatro y nuevamente si queremos tener
exactamente la misma expresión
matemática deberíamos decir que uno
entre la raíz cuadrada de x más 2 para x
diferente de 4 pero podemos ver a que se
aproxima esta función al sustituir x 4
en la expresión simplificada si
sustituimos x con 4 en esta expresión es
igual a 1 entre raíz de 4 que es dos más
dos es decir un cuarto podemos tener
confianza de que este será el límite que
buscamos y si graficar amos la función
original tendríamos un punto de
discontinuidad o un hueco en x 4 pero al
simplificar multiplicando por el
conjugado
podríamos pensar que ese hueco
desaparece y así podemos encontrar el
límite de la función al aproximarse a
ese punto la técnica siguiente tiene que
ver con identidades trigonométricas y
para poder usarla tienen que estar muy
familiarizados con las identidades
trigonométricas por ejemplo el límite
cuando x tiende a cero de seno de x /
seno de 2 x al evaluar esto en x igual a
cero tendremos cero entre cero es la
forma indeterminada por lo que caemos en
esta categoría y pueden darse cuenta de
que este es el límite cuando x tiende a
cero de seno de x podemos reescribir el
denominador como 2 por seno de x por
coseno de x estos se cancelan para
aquellas x diferentes de 0 si queremos
ser matemáticamente precisos seguramente
hay un hueco en la gráfica original pero
para el propósito de encontrar el límite
esto es igual al límite cuando x tiende
a 0 de 1 entre 2 por coseno de x ahora
podemos regresar a la condición verde de
aquí porque ahora si podemos evaluar x 0
2 x coseno de 0 coseno de 0 es 1 así que
esto es igual a un medio
finalmente sin ninguna de estas técnicas
funcionan y más adelante veremos otras
técnicas que usan cálculo pero en
general sin ninguna de estas técnicas
funciona entonces caemos en la categoría
de aproximación una aproximación podemos
hacerla numéricamente al usar valores
que sean mucho muy cercanos al número
del cual queremos encontrar el límite si
queremos encontrar el límite cuando x
tiende a cero
podemos usar 0.00 0001 o usar menos 0.0
0001 si queremos encontrar el límite
cuando x tiende a 4
podemos usar 4.000 0001 y 3.999 999 para
ver qué es lo que ocurre pero es el
último recurso para encontrar el límite
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo